FIRST, UNANSWERED QUESTIONS AND
HIDDEN AGENDAS.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
I’M RING TONIGHT FROM LAS VEGAS
WHERE ALMOST FOUR MONTHS AFTER
THE DEADLIEST MASS SHOOTING IN
U.S. HISTORY THERE’S STILL SO
MANY UNANSWERED QUESTIONS.
IT’S BIZARRE.
WE MADE REPEATED REQUESTS TO
VEGAS P.D. FOR ONE LAW
ENFORCEMENT REPRESENTATIVE TO
UPDATE US ON THE INVESTIGATION
ON AIR.
OF COURSE KILLER STEVEN PADDOCK.
THEY PROVIDED THIS.
A TERSE E-MAIL FROM THE PUBLIC
INFORMATION LAURA -- OFFICER, NO
ONE FROM THE LVMPD WILL BE
WAITING IN ANY INTERVIEWS ABOUT
THE 1 OCTOBER INCIDENT FOR THING
EXTRA HAM ANGLE.
OH, THANKS.
WELL, SOME NEW INFORMATION HAS
TRICKLED OUT OVER THE LAST FEW
DAYS I SAY MOST OF IT, WHEN I
REALLY CULLED THROUGH IT, ONLY
RAISES MORE QUESTIONS.
A LAWYER FOR THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT SAYS CHARGES MAY BE
COMING SOON AGAINST SOME ONE
ELSE AND IS STEMMING FROM WHAT
OFFICERS DISCOVERED IN THAT
MANDALAY BAY HOTEL ROOM ON
OCTOBER 1.
REMEMBER, INSIDE THEY FOUND
PADDOCK DEAD, 47 GUNS, THOUSANDS
OF SPENT CARTRIDGES AND OTHER
EQUIPMENT.
ALL OF THOSE BACKS HE WAS
SOMEHOW ABLE TO GET INTO THE
HOTEL BY HIMSELF.
HIS GIRLFRIEND, LAR MAYOR LOU
DANLEY, HAS ADMITTED, NOW, HER
FINGER PRINCE ARE PROBABLY ON
SOME OF THE AMMO BECAUSE, GET
THIS, SHE HELPED LOAD THE
CARTRIDGES.
I HAVE OTHER INFORMATION ON HER,
TOO, YOU WON’T WANT TO MISS
THAT.
FEDERAL COURT DOCUMENTS THAT
WERE JUST MADE PUBLIC, BALL
GAMES THE PRESS WAS PRESSING FOR
THEM, REVEALED THAT THE FBI AS
EARLY AS OCTOBER 6, JUST FIVE
DAYS AFTER THE SHOOTING, BELIEVE
THAT DANLEY WAS THE MOST LIKELY
PERSON WHO AIDED AND ABETTED
STEVEN PADDOCK.
SO WHERE IS SHE NOW?
WHY DON’T WE HAVE MORE
INFORMATION ON THIS WOMAN?
WHY WERE THEY SO EAGER EARLY ON
TO SAY PADDOCK ACTED ALONE?
AFTER REPORTERS PRESSED FOR THE
CONTENTS OF SEARCH WARRANTS IN
THE AFTERMATH OF THE KILLINGS,
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DID
RELEASE 315 PAGES OF MATERIAL IN
THE LAST FEW DAYS.
BUT THE LAS VEGAS POLICE
DEPARTMENT HAS BASICALLY GONE
RADIO SILENT, CITING CONCERNS
THE ONGOING INVESTIGATION.
WELL, NOW, A FEDERAL JUDGE IS
MULLING THE REQUEST FROM THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS AND THE
LAS VEGAS REVIEW JOURNAL TO
FORCE.
RELEASE OF SEARCH WARRANT
AFFIDAVITS AND OTHER EVIDENCE,
SUCH AS INVENTORIES OF WHAT WAS
OBTAINED FROM THEIR SEARCHS.
VERY IMPORTANT.
THERE ARE MANY QUESTIONS THAT
REMAIN UNANSWERED.
THE PADDOCK HOME WAS RANSACKED
BEFORE AUTHORITIES COULD RETURN.
THAT WAS OCTOBER 10.
AGAIN, WHY WASN’T THAT LOCKED
DOWN?
AND WHAT HAPPENED TO JESUS
CAMPOS, THE MANDALAY BAY
SECURITY GUARD WHO EXCHANGED
FIRE WITH PADDOCK AND WAS
INJURED?
WE SAW HEM ON "ELLEN" THEN NEVER
AGAIN.
WHERE IS THE SURVEIL LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN VIDEO OF PADDOCK
GAMBLING AT THE CASINO, CHECKING
IN WITH ALL OF THOSE BAGS AND
ANYONE ENTERING OR LEAVING HIS
HOTEL ROOM.
WERE WOULDN’T RELEASE THAT?
GIVEN ALL WE’RE LEARNING, WERE
AUTHORITIES SO QUICK TO DECLARE
THIS A LONE WOLF SHOOTING WITH
NO ACCOMPLICES?
>> RIGHT NOW WE BELIEVE IT’S A
SOLE ACTOR, A LONE WOLF.
SOLE SHOOTER.
NO FURTHER THREAT WE WERE AWARE
OF NO, IMMEDIATE THREAT.
>> I WANT TO EMPHASIZE WE
BELIEVE PADDOCK IS SOLELY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS HEINOUS
ACT.
>> Laura: AUTHORITIES SHOULD DO
WHAT’S NECESSARY, OF COURSE, TO
PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
THAT’S A NO-BRAINER.
BUT THEY’VE GONE IN THE OTHER
DIRECTION, I THINK, TRYING TO
LOCK DOWN AS MUCH INFORMATION AS
POSSIBLE.
THEY’RE EXTREMELY DEFENSIVE OVER
THERE AT THE LAS VEGAS POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
WE’RE BIG SUPPORTERS OF THE
POLICE AS YOU KNOW.
AND WE KNOW, BY THE WAY, WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE ABSENCE OF REAL
INFORMATION, CONSPIRACY THEY
ARIES.
YOU SEE THEM ALL OVER THE
INTERNET WHERE THEY INCUBATE AND
COME TO LIFE.
DISTRUST AND RESENTMENT BUILDS
AMONG THE PUBLIC AND THE
VICTIMS’ FAMILIES.
WE’LL HEAR FROM ONE OF THE
SHOOTING SUR VAIFORS COMING UP.
BUT THAT ABSENCE OF INFORMATION,
THE VACUUM, IT’S DON’TLY
UNCONSCIONABLE.
THE BIGGEST, WORST MASS SHOOTING
IN U.S. HISTORY.
THE SAME GAME OF HIDE THE BALL
HAPPENS IN OL HAVE POLITICS AS
WELL.
WE’VE SEEN SCENARIOS WHERE BOTH
GOVERNMENT BODIES AND JOURNAL
INTERESTS END UP REVEALING OR
REPORTING ONLY PART OF THE
STORY.
>>, THE PART THAT THEY NEED TO
ADVANCE THEIR OWN AGENDAS.
OR COVER, YOU KNOW, COVER THEIR
OWN POSTERIORS.
THE PUBLICS INTEREST ISN’T
SERVED IN EITHER CASE WHEN THE
GOVERNMENT DOES IT OR
JOURNALISTS DO IT.
LOOK AT WHAT THE PRESS HAS BEEN
DOING, JUST IN THE PAST WEEK.
THEY’VE BEEN FAT SHAMING DONALD
TRUMP.
>> TELL ME HOW A GUY WHO ITS
McDONALD’S AND KENTUCKY FRIED
CHICKEN, DIET COAX, NEVER
EXERCISES IS IN THAT GOOD A
SHAPE.
>> YOU THINK THAT’S A
PROBLEMATIC?
>> BORDER LINE OBESE K YOU
CHARACTERIZE IT AS EXCELLENT
HEALTH?
>> DO YOU HAVE A WAIST
MEASUREMENT FOR THE PRESIDENT,
THE WEIGHT IS 239, SEEMS JUST
SHY OF OBESITY.
>> Laura: SPEAKING OF WEIGHT,
WHILE THEY’RE TRYING TO PUSH THE
NARRATIVE THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
PHYSICALLY UNFIT FOR THE OFFICE
OR MENTALLY UNFIT, THEY KEEP
INSISTING THAT HE’S A RACIST.
THAT’S THE OTHER STUMP THEY’RE
PULLING.
ALL THE WHILE THEY ADVANCE
COUNTLESS NONSTOP, SUCH
EMOTIONAL IMMIGRATION SOB
STORIES.
>> YOU HAVE THIS CHRISTMAS WHICH
I GUESS IN THE BACK OF YOUR MIND
YOU’RE THINKING THIS IS THE LAST
AT THIS POINT IN TIME, THIS IS
MY HUSBAND, ABOUT TO HAVE TO GO
TO MEXICO, WHAT DID YOU DO WITH
YOUR FAMILY?
>> Laura: BY THE WAY, THAT WENT
ON FOR ABOUT 10 MINUTES.
HOW WAS YOUR CHRISTMAS, HOW DO
YOU FEEL, THOSE TYPES OF REALLY
HARD HITTING INTERVIEWS.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR CNN, HAVE
THEY EVER DONE SUCH AN
EMPATHETIC INTERVIEW WITH
VICTIMS OF AN ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
CRIME OR EXPOSE OF THE AMERICAN
WORKERS DISPLACED BY CHEAP
IMMIGRANT LABOR?
I DON’T THINK I’VE SEEN
INTERVIEWS WITH PRESIDENTS OR
HEADS OF STATE THAT WENT ON AS
LONG AS THAT INTERVIEW.
YOU SAW A TINY SNIPPET.
A BAND OF JACK ALWAYS CIRCLING
ON THE PRESIDENT ON THE MOST
RIDICULOUS MATTERS, THE ONES WE
DISCUSSED, MAJOR STORIES AND
DEVELOPMENTS DOMESTIC AND
INTERNATIONAL ARE GIVEN SHORT
SHRIFT, NORTH KOREA, MIDDLE
EAST, CHINA, THE TRADE WAR, NO,
WE DON’T TALK ABOUT THAT.
WE TALK ABOUT TRUMP’S WAIST AND
HIS BMIA RECENT PUGH CENTURY VA
SAYS AMERICA THINKS THEY HAVE
THE MOST BIASED MEDIA IN THE
WORLD.
ONLY 21% OF TRUMP SUPPORTERS
THINK THE U.S. MEDIA IS FAIR.
I CAN’T BELIEVE IT’S THAT HIGH.
ONLY 55% OPPOSED TO THE
PRESIDENT THINK THE MEDIA IS
FAIR.
I’VE SEEN WORSE POLL THAN THAT.
WHO ARE THE NEW JOHN CONS LORS
OUT THERE, DAVID BRINKLEY,
PEEMENTER JENNINGS, REMEMBER
THEM?
THEY REPORTED ON REAL STORIES,
IT WASN’T ALL ABOUT THEM AND
MAKING THEIR MOMENT IN THE
PRESS.
OF COURSE OUR OWN BRET BAIER,
PLAYS IT DOWN THE MIDDLE.
OTHER THAN BRET WHO ELSE IS OUT
THERE?
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND
CONGRESS HIDE TOO MUCH FROM US
AS WELL.
TO ALL THOSE SENATORS RESISTING
THE TRUMP AGENDA ON TRADE,
IMMIGRATION FOR INSTANCE, WHAT
ARE THE BIG DONORS DEMANDING?
HOW HAS THAT CHANGED YOUR PUBLIC
POSITION ON THESE MAJOR ISSUES,
ISN’T THAT SOMETHING YOU’D LIKE
TO KNOW?
WHO WRITES THESE BILLS THAT ARE
HUNDREDS AND EVEN THOUSANDS OF
PAGES LONG, AND ARE FILLED WITH
ALL SORTS OF GOODIES INSERTED AT
THE LAST MINUTE, ARE THEY
24-YEAR-OLD STAFFERS OTHER
COLLABORATION OF PEOPLE WHO
WRITE THIS JUNK?
THIS IS THE SWAMP AT ITS WORST,
NO WONDER THEY DON’T WANT US TO
KNOW WHAT’S GOING ON.
FOR THE WHITE HOUSE, I’D SAY
OPEN UP AS MUCH AS YOU CAN
WITHOUT HURTING THE DELICATE
PROCESS OF GOVERNING.
BE BFH, BEFORE F-HOLE MEETING,
WAS EXCELLENT.
I HOPE WE SEE MORE OF THAT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT FACTS
AND THEY WANT ANSWERS.
NOT THE BIG BRUSHOFF.
ESPECIALLY FROM THOSE ENTRUSTED
TO SERVE THE PUBLIC GOOD WHETHER
IT’S THE POLICE, FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, AND PUBLIC SERVANTS
IN THE PRESS, THEY CALL
THEMSELVES PUBLIC SERVANTS, TOO.
AT THE SAME TIME, MANY PEOPLE, I
GUESS THEY PROBABLY WANT TO HEAR
LESS FROM POLITICIANS, CERTAIN
POLITICIANS LIKE JEFF FLAKE OR
CORY BOOKER, WHOSE PITIFUL